So this example,
this robot that's going down the hall,
it's got this noise sensor, this is
perfect for sort of a probabilistic
Bayesian filter based tracker, and
the reason is, first of all, it's
going to have some continuous belief
about where it thinks it might be.
Right?
So that's its belief, it's distribution,
it's posterior about where it thinks,
and it's measurements are noisy, and
furthermore, it's really unlikely
that depending upon those
measurements that it will have a nice
Gaussian belief about where things are.
It's belief is going to
be whatever it is.
So we're going to make make use
of a particle filter to do this.
All right?
What you're seeing here,
is this is the prior density.
So here's our little,
should we name our robot?
Sure, what's a good name see, I would
use some like R2D2 kind of name but
then I would get sued by George Lucas.
So we'll call it R3D3.
Okay, so R3D3 is sitting over here and
this here,
this is his prior belief
about where it is right now.
We have no idea how it got that value,
this is it's random distribution, and
you can see it's a pretty uniform
distribution of particles.
Now the sensor reaches out and
it gets the measurement and
let's just suppose it sticks its
stick out and it sees a hole.
What that means is,
the stick doesn't run into anything, so
it says, it's a hole.
Now using the sensor model,
the robot has to evaluate
not where it thinks it is but
first, what's the probability that
I would see a hole if I was
at each of these locations?
So,after the robot sees the hole,
what it has to evaluate is
what is the likelihood that I would've
seen a hole, if I was at this location?
So these values here, these are not the
probability that I'm at that location,
given that I saw a hole, it's
the probability that I would see a hole,
given that I was at that location.
So the reason that it's
highest in the middle
is because even if I've got a wiggly
stick over here, the likelihood
that I see a hole is higher than if I'm
sort of at the edge of the hole, right,
because then I might sometimes run into
the wall, sometimes run into the hole,
and that's why I have this nice
tight little distribution like that.
Okay?
So remember,
that's not p of x given the hole,
it's the probability that I would
see a hole given that I was an x.
Then what do we do?
Well, in a particle filter
we just multiply p of z,
given x, probability the hole given x,
times my prior distribution for
everyone of these xs, okay?
So that's what this
distribution is down here,
that is the multiplication of
the prior times the likelihood,
and in math, remember, the belief is
proportional to the prediction, or
my belief prior, that's this here, times
my likelihood, that's this value here,
and then I have to normalize the whole
thing in order to get a new belief.
Okay, that's why I'm doing that.